the Joe Rogan experience hey I watched
alien covenant the other day I didn't
know that Jesse
Smollett he was in that shirt de
Chappelle bit on that as oh my god it
was made so funny it was amazing that
dude has to live with that forever when
you get taken down by Dave [ __ ]
Chappelle oh this one a top three
comedians of all time dedicated ten
minutes to you and they're trying to act
like there's this movement now to try to
act like oh he's only accepted now by
conservatives but that's just not true
with Dave Chappelle there's not
hilarious just not it's just not true
it's nonsense well this is this is the
problem with woek culture it's it's
reductionist and it's delusional it's
just it's not real and they're trying to
for they're trying to push this
narrative as if they're echo chambers
whether it's their blogs or their
Twitter groups when they have you know
they have these band group so that band
people that haven't even interacted with
them and they're interacting with people
in this bubble and they believe that
this is how the world thinks that's how
you get something like that Rotten
Tomatoes review of Dave Chappelle's
where it got 0% by 5:00 woke critics
then they release it to the general
public gets 99% there you go and it's
also this spring back effect where
people know you're [ __ ] with them and
then they go oh okay well you guys are
[ __ ] so the people that are saying
that Dave Chappelle special is bad they
become the enemy and then so Dave
becomes the hero and then even if you
didn't like it you're gonna say you
loved it ya know and and and the another
thing is they act like he's always been
politically incorrect yes look at hit
look at Chapelle show which was you know
I was in high school we all watch this
pal show and I thought it was like the
most brilliant thing ever and the idea
that he ever crosses some sort of a line
that Steve Shappell the whole poised to
cross the line point of it perpetual
line steppers since day one that's why
he's so funny
[Applause]